[Music]  Kourtney Kardashian is newly single and  hotter than ever there's just too much  going on the Keeping Up with the  Kardashians star and her boyfriend of  nearly two years unis Benjamin ecent Lee  called it quits and a 39 year old showed  the 25 year old model what he's missing  hosting this sexy shot to Instagram in  the pic court lounges poolside rocking a  neon green itty-bitty song bikini  putting her killer bod on full display  the caption sweet Sunday boyfriend  Courtney and Eunice started dating in  2016 but a source recently told et that  their age gap ultimately played a factor  in their split I have no idea it's in  God's hands quote Eunice is young and  although mature for his age he and  Courtney are at different stages in  their lives  [Music]  [Applause]